India known for its Rich agricultural
Heritage boasts a diverse and vibrant
farming sector with over 157 million
hectares of arable land the country is a
major producer of crops such as rice
wheat and sugarcane in these
agricultural practices range from
traditional methods to modern techniques
including organic farming and precision
agriculture the country's agricultural
sector employs a significant portion of
its population and plays a crucial role
on ensuring food security for its 1.3
billion people India's farming prowess
truly shines as it continues to
contribute to the global food supply
[Music]